hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
and we're here in Barcelona to wrap up
2016 it's been a great year for dota 2
so here are your top 10 best plays of
the year in two seconds what lives there
first and miracle has to make the
decision whether or not he's gonna try
and style complexity just go for it he
chops out one of the supports gets the
Omni slash on the other main while limp
is watching helplessly unable to save
his teammates windle's gonna have to
play around this fountain wait for Lynn
to try and save him and save feet
brother he says he's got the dole ready
to go they can actually beat miracle
nobody get off the Hillywood somebody
stop that one note into the trees little
kitty is choking it out and now Swindell
melons he's left alone against miracle
you've all seen this story time and time
again miracle and hit by Whisnant snare
in general once back in he's dying a
Firefly though wow this is I don't know
what happened to Daisy yeah it's got a
little too deep artstyles there he's
trying to bring down yang will not be
able to get him and now the problem is
going to come in [ __ ] you're wrong one
more Auto Attack will bring him down but
it's going to cost them too chin and fYI
gotta give ditch you're on the what for
on this way out the door in
that one's gonna be careful is gonna be
meted from behind leading a fair amount
of damage you can't mess around with
trance one more Ottawa tackle do it and
he does and it should double back
century Jews the century who water
flavored it boy he predicts the century
placement god he's gonna now rub for the
creeps if he gets to he denies himself
e'er okay I thought maybe he's gonna try
he may still do it he's going into a
Corning he wants the shadow walk and his
textured oh why is gonna make it out are
you kidding
let's go to the Korea snipe of course he
like a hole here knobby you think we
don't have to migrate is Korea taking
the camp bounty hunter proposed no you
know daddy's low he's all not active on
the map and it is now he got the courier
are you serious
my son indeed the moon will go down take
us the man to find that kill but they're
looking for more miracle comboing up the
bag happening while the double-dipping
blah something will save Raven but it
won't save the rest of his team your
scepter spinning around you'll just keep
hitting up as he ever going to hit the
ground right now
the sky diver Raven will finally drop a
double for Creek a triple for miracle
thank you very much I'll take one of
those myself as a souvenir home MSS
considering the burrowstrike fall but
they all get fatally wounded they have
to bow
shall travel down he's down the one
leaving the yard old chicken who was
also left by the fatal books and even
together they untethered with a glimpse
back they go again
table fires until he heard get team one
and that is the epitome of a disaster as
long as eerily frantic threshold you
want to go in scandals and reign to this
entry they know exactly is sacred you
are getting live from this one will be
the sole survivor before his teammates
are they just got called guard moving
forums for you looking for Anna playing
around with in the back of different
charity news for spawn through the rebar
murder in Sweden there's gonna be the
late again trunks keep matter I know
what
put the son of a
to keep
is
[Applause]
like in his hands
maybe morale builder so no slip-up they
could simply just smoke up and finish it
off on the next fire back Adam I don't
think maybe next time cuz there is way
too much armor on a four-wheeler
in the world
[Music]
one day
Pete maybe the bishop like they're
grouping up they're so lame they have to
try and use those the tower but npp have
to be careful how he's going to drop the
old burrowstrike comes in a return for
b-1b if it's going to be charged up and
here we go on to Febby bring him down
low but the dispenser destroyer for dubu
now the demonic pleasure be won't be MVP
looking for the turn around they take
down a second double kill for them e
horizon falling low but Gabby hats on
the damage he just takes the Warlock but
he's always selling gonna pay of his own
life sighs in the morn re Gabby's
styling over the wall it gets himself a
double kill a deal is true at all
can they actually kill the pun look at
the frame break back but yaoi flings
down and jump back a Gabby Gabby Gabby
oh my god he wasn't gonna do to stop it
lasts abundance here from diamond Oh a
big moving crunch from KP a follow-up
combo comes out from SC as he shreds
right through them quickly taking out
universe from the fight no roar for you
sir no buyback will be had newbie sweep
through the competition now but here
comes the bounce-back from eg sumail
shrugging on in and suddenly it's going
to be who nine on the retreat now I'll
turn around there goes the Eclipse
sumail does not want any piece of it
Artie's gonna be forced to pounce to low
ground SC dishes up tornado will be only
ten Kansai turns it back link it's going
to be popping out getting it to burst
like a nice hole there gets the right
click that's gonna get side Tiffany
blast boom on in art easy stuck in that
same wall will be able to pounce and
make it to the high drop but he's still
so slow looks like
make it out trouble here but the
onslaught continues as s he gets the
next site going down and taking out crit
now sumail and RTC both looks a tag team
him but he's going to be able to get up
the tornado he gets the full promise and
says back the hell up
I'm the true 9k here found out before me
artis II cannot have a say in the matter
as I see still canoes to go to work
Funai will lose that aegis and now EG
we're going to make them pay a fullback
with the eggs with the putter combo
coming out the boat is there but SC
moves on it looks to go for our TZ and
still will get the grab quick get six
turns back tornado root of are still
finally going to be able to get the
roar-off but it's in a bad spot outside
the base will it be enough it will not
screw bales here now but ultimately will
not be able to help them out with the
deep here's the buyback of art easy as
it looks like this could be the final
say for EG
he is just desperate now refuses to
accept the SCA [ __ ] is just doing so
much work I see not allowing it get the
hell off these bumps in with a deafening
blast blinks in front of them tight he's
going to be there with a crush holy hell
I am ever it is just non-stop don't even
try it they cannot do a thing about it
I have never seen a single player just
Mickey to book he made the order Billy
still alive no juggernaut is good to go
he's gonna be able to take that Mahler
x-range rank off next mailing or ringy
town i flat coming in it is rain Frank
that's gonna be make as the magnet field
DVD either buddy is huh spy pack anymore
except this warlock key home going to be
incredibly satisfied but they want to
keep pushing forward they know that this
board of this axe can't help out they
can catch the mail or PPC there's gonna
be another here with no buyback the
disruption say from side can they get
PPD out he gets a force F away but no ta
she comes out out of here repressor
activated biome 11 not going to get the
chance for a second primal war he's
gonna get
volunteer he's down and out evil
geniuses still fiber but here comes that
on these last bouncing around their
shattered even open if he was going as I
put it the mail just down there but he
still managed to get himself away in the
back light the spaceless for you in the
past
and now he's going to run himself away
universe says these copy like a night
deep shave my beard
[Applause]
the old way of saying he's back inside
he's already taken down one of the tier
fours and he's trying to get me beat
even eat Latinas in full on collecting
they're holding this event here and if
they kill a chicken
Hey
one-five
15 feet on it began
ow
they are staring down the spectral beam
the gospel flyboy and Randy's afterlife
he goes on the back for the big campus
if they'd ring around it
stop
thank the rapper
the turnaround for the ribbing was
massive the buybacks of vinegar and team
secret own life now and there you have
it
do you agree with our list or do you
feel like we missed something
let us know in the comments below I'm
Lisa lo from the score eastwards and we
will see you guys next year